so like aquafina is this actress you've
seen her in uh shang chi and a bunch of
other movies crazy rich asians and she
keeps on getting criticized for using a
black scent she's an asian actress she's
half korean half chinese a friend of
mine we did you know back in the day
girl code i think it was together but um
and she just keeps on getting criticized
for using this black scent and uh
well first of all what do you guys think
about it is it her accent
so here's the thing
when you're from new york
she's from new york she's from queens
so it's like what are we talking about
like
but you know and see that's the thing
that maybe you guys understand as like
uh canadians but like black people are
from canada because like you guys have
an accent from your part of canada yeah
i understand like you all sound like
you're from quebec okay it's different
than when you're from toronto and the
toronto accent just popped up like
a year ago
like these [ __ ] sounded like
they were from new york five years ago
and now all of a sudden
i love toronto but it feels like they're
adopting an identity like if you listen
to tory lanez talk he talks he's from
new york where do you find my guy
every once in a
[Music]
[Applause]
while so
but i think that they're adopting
identity that are from the influential
cultures that are in the city right and
that's what we all do right so if you
grow up in new york yes you're going to
code switch i'm going to speak one way
around my parents and one way around my
friends yeah and i think that we all do
that the crazy thing about her and why i
always defend her is it's like what
accent you want her to have yo she gotta
have an asian accent is that what you
want or you she gotta talk white what
you're basically saying is hey you gotta
talk white and the reality is she grew
up in queens maybe grew up with more
black folk than she did white folk and
that's gonna be the people that
influenced her accent the most
all right
if if
she grew up in queens bruh i know she's
around i tell her this all the time i'm
like yo that's yours you're a product of
this city don't let anybody tell you how
you can or can't talk now here's the
thing i do understand the frustration
and we were talking to our boy derek
poston opens up on on the road for us
and i and he was bringing up this point
i understand the frustration of black
people where he's like yo if i quote
unquote black sent it up i'm scary or
dangerous to people when other cultures
lean in it's endearing or funny it's
funny that this asian girl has a blacker
quote-unquote but we would call this a
new york accent but if you're not from
new york it's a black accent like that
is all of a sudden comical right so it's
like i understand that frustration if
you're black you're going yo why when i
do this [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] up and dangerous and when
this asian girl does it it's hilarious
yeah yeah but that's just
comedy's
weird
like that yeah it's not it's not precise
but besides that um
yeah she's from queens she she is it's
like that people it's not
asian people that speak like that it's
people from queens that speak like that
yeah
i mean
will vicky get the same treatment well
nikki well vicky vicky yeah yeah
whatever but where's she from i'm pretty
sure she's from like used or some [ __ ]
but that's her accent right from what i
know so my thing is this might be that
might be a little cat yeah i don't know
i'm pretty sure it's reaction but
um the main thing i was going to say is
i think it just comes down to the
context i understand the struggle i
understand where the hurt comes from
whether it be with the braids and the
box braids and everyone's switching up
the names of the hairstyles because a
white girl put on i get that yeah but we
can't throw away context because you
feel that outreach you gotta understand
like there's an individual on the other
side of that that you don't know that
you are crediting to
a group think or a group idea which is
the same issue that you have being dealt
to you you get i'm saying you're being
marginalized
you're being pigeonholed when you speak
a certain way and now you're making and
you're pigeonholing someone else
removing their identity yeah their
individualism right or the place that
they grew up in all that and just
putting them in the people were like
appropriating your culture no that's her
culture yeah right so you can't just
meet with that and again that comes back
to the rogan thing earlier where it's
like
people don't want to take the time to go
beyond the two-minute clip that they saw
or anything like that to do a simple
google church to learn about folks they
don't have the energy yeah they just saw
her they'd heard her speak and they went
she's part of that yeah i think the
solution is not punishing someone for
like you know being a part of it it
should be trying to create a more
accepting society that doesn't feel
uncomfortable and black people talk
black yes you know what i mean yeah like
it's the same thing with like cornrows
like when a black woman wears cornrows
in the workplace it's unprofessional she
can't wear hair like that when david
beckham does it wow look how cool this
guy is yeah i don't think we should
punish david beckham for wearing
cornrows i think we should accept black
women
and i understand black people's
frustration with that but it's easier to
punish one person than to try to make a
whole society change that's true
that's true so you're taking out that
frustration on that one part they become
the figurehead for your frustration i'm
gonna make you feel how all the how
society may be made me feel yeah yes i
don't know how it works and that's a
human interaction sorry country that's
okay that's just like this knee-jerk
thing that we do and we can we cannot be
proud of our behavior we can do [ __ ]
up things and recognize it but i do
understand the impulse to be critical
you're like you're just like what the
[ __ ]
i've been doing this [ __ ] and it's a
problem they do it and it's celebrated
but i like what you guys are saying at
least that you have a context to go like
that's where she's from that's how the
[ __ ] she talks yeah because if she spoke
an asian accent nobody would be upset
about it even though it wouldn't be
natural for her
right nobody would say a single [ __ ]
thing because she's conforming to our
idea of what it should be rather than
yeah
with that that's [ __ ] up that is funny
that is [ __ ] up that we no you should
speak like that
i don't want to be that guy but i'm like
aren't you going to doing the same thing
how about this a black person grows up
in the suburbs speaks doesn't speak like
they're from the hood they get on
television speak the same way everyone
starts looking at in fact why are you
trying to be white no it's the
environment
it would be weird if i hear some guy who
grew up in a gated community like it's
like when i hear these rappers who grew
up in gated communities talk about oh
i'm shooting through keypads and all
this stuff [ __ ] you live behind a gate
like why you talk about thug life that's
not you that's inauthentic that's the
issue but you being true to yourself and
and talking about stuff that's real for
you now you're being white so it's like
but i get this
yeah i get that all the time because in
french
i don't know how aquafina got brought up
and anything and stuff my parents came
here and they understood they understood
what having an accent and what not
bothering people and
so my parent
i was not allowed to speak creole with
my parents i was allowed to speak uh
creole with uh my aunts and my my my
extended family but with your parents
no i was french because they wanted you
to be nice because they understood that
the importance of having a good french
yeah right and
when i stepped on when i said an
interview sometimes and i speak french
with the interview which is french
quebecer i speak quebecer which is
therefore the different type of french
with its accent
what i said was the accent is going to
be different it's not going to be like
an accent from france right
my
black followers are like why are you
trying to be white i grew up like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah if i went to
school i speak with a with a creole
accent i would get beat if i go back
home and i speak with a quebecer
accident not a proper actor proper
quote-unquote i would get beat yeah so i
co-switch all the time like that's what
i do it's also it's not because you have
different accent it's also part of who i
am yeah it's part of who we all are yeah
yeah
highly intelligent social individual is
going to have these different codes that
they can speak with right if you're
speaking one specific way you go talk to
your priest you're going to do the exact
same things you talk to your friends no
you're going to change certain words and
you're going to change certain tones all
that kind of stuff but your mom is from
my mom's from scotland when she's with
her family that scottish accent pops up
and you're in your
all that and all that she can be
uh asian wherever the hell she's from
yeah and also from queens and be part of
that and that makes
who she who she is but the thing is
people want
a clear distinction of what oh you're
like that you're that yeah be asian
satisfy my feelings yes you should
satisfy my feelings it's selfish and
yeah i don't understand how you then
it's fake it's not like that it's not
exactly like that but whatever again i i
think goes back to the whole thing we're
trying to cope with this influx
information these new faces new people
and we don't have enough time to see
them as individuals so we place them in
groups so we can understand them yeah
this i think a lot of these issues
thinking's hard whether it's
misinformation all this stuff is just a
reflection of like the new technologies
that we're absorbing that our brains and
our but like we're not meant
to see millions of people we're not
meant to scroll and see a different
person our brains have a hard time
internalizing all this stuff and so
we're having like these malfunctions
where we're having almost like inhuman
responses to other human beings but it's
impossible to be
empathetic to be kind to be
understanding with millions of people
that you're seeing all the time yeah
exactly make it quick for you to process
exactly an asian you have to speak
here's an example here's an example i'm
walking down the street and this is
something like you see somebody they
look threatening you're just gonna
assume that about them you're gonna
profile them right you're gonna act
accordingly right if i see a bald white
dude with like tattoos and i think he's
a skinhead i'ma just move accordingly
right
that's who you were imagining
[Laughter]
me too me too yeah
so
you do that but you have to imagine we
aren't built for that because if you go
back a long time you had your village
you had your neighborhood yes
you knew everybody there it wasn't
normal to walk across somebody who
looked threatening because you knew
everybody and if they weren't there
everybody's like yo who's that walking
through our street yeah so we have to
also acknowledge that
everything has changed so fast and we
haven't adapted exactly no exactly white
people are good can i ask you one
question
yes miles go what if someone takes a new
york accent what if they don't have it
it happens i have a i have a prime
example who's that canada's most
handsome man ryan gosling has a new
yorker has a new york accent yeah new
yorker he not new yorker he's canadian
he grew up
uh wanting a tougher accent so he
started copying marlon brando as a kid
how do you feel now is he making is he
stealing your culture no that is
different he's appropriate but if you're
someone who lives in new york for
extended period of time you're just
going to speak like us it's just what it
is it's like how many years not only is
it cool yo i bet you i bet you if we
were in the south if i lived in the
south for [ __ ] you won't have it
three i'm gonna start having southern
dude when we were in miami i bet i
started saying bro
more bro you were
that sandwich is poor
everything about that sandwich is it
should be wrapped in plastic yeah that
is a poor [ __ ] sandwich it's about
their communism food yeah they're not
allowed
leave it bro nobody trying to eat that
uh-uh
it's ham and pork
yeah double up yeah they're like what's
going on dude yeah yeah but you know if
you understand the food situation in
cuba you can't be too mad at them it's
the best they could do
yeah but they're here now
bro cuba food's fine what are you
talking about
[Music]
all over this [ __ ]
is
on the ryan gosling [ __ ] though
like when you come from certain
backgrounds you learn that assimilating
is part of surviving or like
adapting right so for like my parents
like they understood this
to survive in vancouver canada god
forbid he didn't have that new york
accent
you wouldn't have made it what would
have happened i mean would he become
part of the mickey mouse club who knows
he sounded canadian bro
he was from saskatchewan wouldn't have
worked try to smooth talk as ryan
gosling from saskatchewan yes it
probably wouldn't have worked but
survival may be the wrong word maybe not
in regards to brian gosling but i do
know like so for some folks when they
immigrate to a certain spot they start
taking on the accent like yes they
weren't born there but i understand a
portion of why they do it because it
just you don't want to stand up because
standing out oftentimes is a bad thing
if you want to just leave a simple life
you just want to go to work and like not
have your boss single you out because
the way that you talk
he worries that it upsets customers or
whatever so i'm not i'm not mad at
because i understand why it's there like
i'm not mad at somebody who goes to a
customer service job and all of a sudden
they you know they're not like hey what
up cuz they're like yes how can i do my
name is
how about this i worked at a
call center we used to do things for
like charities so we call people up to
scam them and
these are all scams and
i would not say my name is abba of
course not i'd say hey my name is
michelle i would say in the french
accent and i'll be like and and i would
notice
that the customers were more receptive
to me once i had a name that they could
identify with when i used to call it i
used to have recordings they would just
hang up
so i learned that if i wanted to keep
this job and to make money when i'm
struggling i had to adapt my accent so
yeah yeah oh yeah they would hang up
yeah you go to hang up bodegas in canada
i don't go hey what's up no i speak like
them
all right
all right
aren't
and i'm like they're like oh he's us
cool not a threat yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i think it's natural to do this
yeah yeah i think that's normal yeah
i i understand the frustration when you
see it but i do think it is normal
especially if you're living in a place
yeah i didn't know that ryan gosling did
that [ __ ]
and he never even lived in new york
no i grew up uh watched a lot of marlon
brando movies and was like yo that's
tough any of the dudes the actor who
sucked dick
marlon brando oh the actor
what he's the gay actor right marlon
brando
didn't he [ __ ] richard pryor
whoa
i'm pretty sure richard bly sucks a
marlin right now i'll look it up yeah
yeah you didn't know he was gay i didn't
know was it quincy jones
i'm not crazy brother i'm not crazy i'm
not going to look at me like this is the
fish people this is this is not some
legendary [ __ ] google that so this is an
article from tmz says uh richard pryor's
widow says yes he did bang marlon
brandon let's go yeah sorry
you got really happy crazy you got
really happy someone [ __ ] someone else
i need to know really happy some dude
this is from no this is on tmz all over
the
place
i think quincy jones yeah the whole
article where it was airing some [ __ ]
out no
i mean richard probably did say he
sucked a dick
i mean at least he sucked the best
like that [ __ ] randall was one
of the best he's a new york accent after
you blow brando can you get 100 he blew
it right into his [ __ ] mouth
dude you couldn't help but speak with a
new york accent dude
[Applause]